Welcome back to 8.701.
Our second part of
the chapter on QCD
is on elastic
electron-proton scattering.
So elastic electron-proton
scattering in general
has a long history, going
back into the 1960s.
Very famous examples are the
MIT-SLAC or SLAC-MIT experiment
which led to the
Nobel Prize in physics
for Jerry Friedman, Henry
Kendall, and Richard Taylor
in 1990.
And the most recent
and highest energetic
electron-positron experiments
were conducted at DESY
in Hamburg, at the
so-called HERA ring.
And we'll go back into
those experiments.
They are famous for not just
elastic electron-positron
scattering, but
inelastic and deep
inelastic electron-positron
scattering,
which is going to be
subject of future lectures.
What we are trying to do here--
you might still wonder why
this is topic of a QCD lecture.
What we're trying to do is
study the structure of protons.
And the way to look at this
is in these Feynman diagrams,
we're using this photon here
to probe into the structure
of the proton.
We can start from this
scattering process, which
we already calculated,
and we derived the Mott
scattering
cross-section formula.
But we really want to reconsider
this proton now as a prop.
In elastic scattering, we are
not destroying the proton,
so we leave the proton intact
in the scattering process.
We do know that the proton
is not a point-like particle.
So if you want to
now study the proton,
we have to take into
account that it's
built out of constituents
and that it has an extension.
It's not point-like anymore.
And one way to do
this is by analyzing
the Fourier transform of the
charge density functions.
Remember, the photon couples
to charged particles.
And so when we use the
photon to probe a proton,
it probes the charge
distribution inside the proton.
So we build a Fourier transform
of the charge distribution,
and then can extend
the cross-section
from a point-like cross-section
via this Fourier transform
of this charge distribution.
Great.
In electron-positron scattering,
there is another point.
It's not just the
extension of the proton,
but also the fact that
the proton carries recoil.
And so we need to use
two form factors in order
to describe the
cross-section fully.
So let's have a look
at the amplitude.
Again, we can start
from where we left off
with the electron-positron
scattering,
or electron-muon scattering, and
write down our matrix elements,
and just now for the proton.
What we do here is we modify
the vertex of the proton.
And the modification is
parameterized in those two
factors, describing
the cross-section
of the matrix
elements' amplitude
with two form factors.
The one, which just looks like
a modification of our spin-1/2
particle--
you remember there's
this gamma factor,
and then this is
going to be a number.
And the other one is a
little bit more complicated.
There are the Pauli matrix
here and another number,
and it's normalized by
the mass of the photon.
All right.
So this is just a
parameterization.
We haven't done
much physics here.
We have just parameterized
the distribution.
If you then use this, we
can, as I just described,
calculate the
cross-section again,
using this very same
parameterization,
and get to this formula here
in the laboratory frame.
This looks rather complicated,
but if you go back to our form
factor definitions and set this
one to 0 and this one to 1,
you get back-- and
the same here--
we should get back to our
Mott scattering result which
we had before, so
really extended
the discussion to
extended objects,
and considering the charge
distribution and also
the recoil in the proton.
So this is great.
Historically-- so this
is not a new idea.
This has been done
for generations.
Historically, the
parameterization
was done slightly different.
And so we introduced the linear
combination of those form
factors, and those
are typically referred
to as the electric and
the magnetic form factors,
so GE and GM.
This formula here-- and
this is just algebra,
going from previous
formula to this--
it's called the Rosenbluth
cross-section formula.
All right?
So this is just, if you find
this in particle physics
booklets or in nuclear
physics booklets,
this is what is meant by this.
The only thing we did here is
extended the Mott scattering
formula using extended objects,
extend the charge distribution
to the [INAUDIBLE]
[? Rosenbluth ?] formula.
All right.
But we have done that by using a
Fourier transform of the charge
distribution.
So if you now measure
the cross-section,
we can infer the charge
distribution of the proton,
and with that the radius, the
charge radius, of the proton.
This has been done, and
we find that the RMS--
the root mean square--
of the proton charge
is 0.81 femtometers.
So that's the charge.
And this measured
charge is still today
a hot topic in particle
physics, because
its measured distributions do
not quite agree with the theory
predictions.
But you see this here
parameterized for this value
of the proton charge.
The theory and the global fits
to the data don't quite agree.
You would have to go to slightly
higher values of the proton
radius in order to have theory
agree with the experiments.
So I'll leave it here.
The next lecture now--
we split this lecture in
two parts, the elastic
and the inelastic scattering.
The next lecture will be
on inelastic scattering,
where we will break the
proton apart and learn
about the structure
of the proton.